oh you're gonna love it he's pretty much
out for everything always a pleasure to
see you Lucy
it's time
excuse me ladies seems like you know the
only ones want a piece of me I see you
later
Gianni
I'd like to say it's a pleasure to see
you online earth outside my club is not
welcome back everyone it's Charlie press
F in the chat for the multiverse this is
going to be my crisis on Infinite Earths
episode 3 video there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs we'll break it all down if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter egg
videos we'll do a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best theory for how this is all going to
end careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet but we'll do top 10
WTF and easter eggs as we go along
starting with number 10 the birds of
prey cameo at the top we go to earth 203
because 2003 is the date when the
original birds of prey CW television
series ended we see the hunters
character from that TV show cameo
talking to Oracle Barbara Gordon also
played by the actress from that TV show
she didn't come on screen but she was in
the comm so the actress did record voice
over dialogue just like the actor who
played Captain colds didn't come back to
be on screen but he did come back to
record a new voice over dialogue and be
the AI of the Waverider during the
crossover they wiped that earth then
number 9 WTF we learned by the last
three Paragons so they've already found
four but they named the last three as
the flash is the paragon of love which
seems like a weird choice even the other
characters say HM that's new that's kind
of weird why would you pick love is the
one that Barry gets to be martian
manhunter is the paragon of honor
they've kind of been setting him up for
a bigger arc this season I think because
there's just been a tragic lack of
Martian Manhunter in previous years
crossovers and they wanted to find a
bigger role for him during this
crossover you have to remember that
Martian Manhunter in terms of his
superpowers is one of the most Opie
characters that they have but they
barely use him during any of the
crossovers in previous years so I think
making him a Paragon is a way for them
to kind of address that during this
year's crossover but then Ryan Choi is
named as the last Paragon of humanity
now I knew he was coming on the TV show
because we saw pictures of him and they
announced that he was coming on the TV
show but because Brandon Rath is
actually gonna leave legends of tomorrow
this season I believe that he's going to
permanently replace him and become the
new version of the atom just like they
did in the comics so the Ryan Choi that
they introduced you'll recognize is
ostrich Chow from Supernatural and just
like in the comics he's a ray palmer
fanboy he's a professor at Ivy town
which is where the Ray Palmer character
comes from in the comics so they try to
be as awesome
to the comics as they could within what
they've already done with the Ray Palmer
character so far I don't know if they're
gonna give him a new version of the atom
suit to wear when he eventually joins
legends of tomorrow but I think
eventually they'll get their Diggle also
comes back to for the first time we
haven't seen Diggle yet but remember
there's still two more episodes of the
crossover and each show's characters
leaf as secondary characters tend to be
bigger in those shows episodes number
eight though the monitor explains the
ante monitors plan so obviously if
you've read the comic book crisis on
Infinite Earths you've already noticed a
bunch of big changes that they've made
he explains that the anti-monitor wants
to wipe the multiverse and replace it
with one antimatter universe so
replacing it with a single universe one
of the reasons why he was doing this in
the comics doing just one antimatter
universe instead of doing an antimatter
multiverse is because that way he would
be more powerful they get into the
origin story of the anti-monitor during
this there are a couple Easter eggs at
the end of the episode that all
addressed during the video to number
seven Sisko finds the source of the
antimatter wave is right near STAR Labs
where Nash Wells was trying to get into
that special room with the symbols of
the seven different Paragons the monitor
gives him his powers back we find out
why he has to become vibed because in
all the visions at the beginning of the
flash this season you see him running in
his vibe costume while the antimatter
wave is washing over everyone they wind
up using his abilities in a couple of
different ways the first one is to pull
the memory of how to enter that room
from pariah Welles mind because he says
that when the anti-monitor
turned him into pariah he lost most of
his memories but he also explains how he
had been manipulated this whole time so
he explains all the backstory for how he
had really been following the
anti-monitor trying to kill him instead
of the monitor like he had originally
thought number 6 WTF the book of Destiny
is still a big thing during the episode
Supergirl wants to use it to bring back
earth 38 but let's Luthor tries to
explain that it'll turn her mind into
jelly it requires so much willpower even
to just do what he did go around killing
Superman took a lot of energy they have
a bit of a fake-out Batman V Superman
moment when Batwoman whips out the
Kryptonite that she stole from old
Batman thinking that she might have to
use it on Supergirl to stop her from
trying to use the book of Destiny the
whole reason why it was important to
stop her is because if she wasn't
successful it would result in this giant
feedback loop blowing
rest of them and the way brighter up
number five was the Lucifer cameo this
is actually a big payoff a lot of people
had wondered all year long if he was
gonna actually have a cameo they'd go to
earth 666 of course that would be the
earth that Lucifer is on but Constantine
is going to him to get help in entering
purgatory so he's the one that gives
them that special car that allows them
to enter the version of Lian Yu that is
purgatory very funny joke there because
Lian Yu literally translates to
purgatory in Chinese that's the way they
decided on the arrow TV show but when
they started the arrow TV show they
didn't know that they'd be able to do
crisis on Infinite Earths or that Leone
you would literally become the purgatory
of the arrow verse but as you can see
retro actively a lot of things do work
out that way so it is a nice coincidence
that it all worked out in the end they
have a funny joke about how to pronounce
the Constantine name he says Constantine
Constantine says no it's Constantine and
he says whatever I don't care
that's because originally the
character's name is supposed to be
pronounced Constantine but so many
people in pop culture all over the world
the last 10 to 15 years especially since
the Keanu Reeves Constantine movie
started pronouncing it Constantine that
has been adopted as the most common
pronunciation of the name but if you're
an old-school Hellblazer a comic book
fan you're probably one of the people
that's screaming no it's supposed to be
pronounced Constantine when he looks at
Diggle and says you remind me of my
brother that's his brother amenadiel of
the angel that he's talking about and
just to explain how he exists within the
arrowverse now because they're sort of
canonizing him to the arrowverse the
whole idea is is that there are infinite
numbers of universes but there's only
one God there's only one devil only one
heaven and only one hell so when they go
to purgatory to fight all of her soul
there's only one version of purgatory
but number 4 the black lightning cameo
black lightning actually has a much
bigger role he'll be back I believe in
either part 4 or part 5 of the crossover
so it's not just a couple quick scenes
that you saw in this episode he will be
back for more later they get inside the
anti monitors lab and they find the
flash of earth 90 Barry Allen played by
John Wesley Shipp who's trapped on the
cosmic treadmill or a version of the
cosmic treadmill from the comics
powering the ante monitors antimatter
gun that's also a big Easter Egg for the
end of crisis on Infinite Earths
in the comics so the flesh sacrificed
himself
everybody has seen this comic book panel
they read conned his death a little bit
later but originally what it was is the
anti-monitor was just gonna use it to
destroy the last remaining earths and
the flash ran around it so fast that he
destroyed the gun and that's how he
turned into pure speed force energy
seemingly dying the reason why they
killed off the Barry Allen flash during
that original comic book run is because
they were transitioning to a bunch of
new versions of characters and that's
when Wally West became the main version
of the flash so that was back during the
80s but of course eventually Geoff Johns
brought the flashback during flash
rebirth in there was a lot of mark
Wade's flash run in the 90s where they
teased Barry Allen coming back but
originally it was just DC cleaning house
they're like we got all these characters
all this crazy continuity that doesn't
make sense we'll develop a big comic
book event to either kill people off or
fix our continuity so number three the
flash of Earth 90s sacrifices himself
the monitor said the flash had to die
but he didn't say which one I think a
lot of people had this theory that there
would be a twist and it would wind up
being this Barry Allen in not the main
grant gustin version of Barry Allen it
was a great way to send him out you
probably heard the theme song from the
original flash 90s TV show they even
took a clip of the 90s flash TV series
as a flashback moment when he was
sacrificing himself he also explained
that he eventually married that version
of Tina McGee which makes sense but
apparently she died at some point in the
past black lightning is also helping him
out during all this - he recited his
catchphrase from his TV show and they
said that they wiped black lightnings
earth but by the end of the episode they
wipe all universes so it doesn't really
matter that much number two though
confirming my long-running theory about
Oliver for the past couple of months
Oliver is going to become the new
spectre of the arrowverse multiverse
that is because remember one God one
devil one heaven one hell one version of
The Spectre they fight all of her soul
and he's in a version of the original
hood costume the very first one from
season 1 but then right around the
corner Jim Corrigan walks up and says in
another life I used to be a police
officer but then I became the spectre
the embodiment of God's divine justice
in Wrath he says now it's Oliver's turn
in oliver says okay i have to do this so
if you're not familiar with who the
spectre is he's one of the most powerful
characters in the
see multiverse he was a big part of
comic-book crisis on Infinite Earths
there's a big comic book cover with him
on it going up against the anti-monitor
Marc Guggenheim one of the producers on
the air over show and one of the people
that helped engineer this big crossover
and writer said that when they were
pitching the crossover to the network
they pitched them five different comic
book covers to explain how their
crossover would work of the 12 total
comic book covers from the original
crisis on Infinite Earths my guess is is
that one of the comic book covers was
this one with the specter on it and
that's going to represent the arrow
episode of the crossover part four you
see this giant splash page from the end
of comic book crisis with everybody in
the multiverse going up against the
anti-monitor with the specter up really
high going at him that'll probably be a
moment that they try to replicate for
the actual ending of the big crossover
during part 5 think of that as sort of
their avengers endgame Avengers Assemble
moment of course they're probably gonna
replicate some version of that on the TV
show but because Oliver is becoming the
new version of The Spectre that's
probably explaining where he goes after
this year's crossover because the arrow
show is ending they've killed off Oliver
Queen technically he's dead but now
Stephen Amell can come back at will
Yoda style just popping up wherever he
wants to because now he's become the
literal embodiment of justice and
vengeance inside the arrow verse so the
sort of taking the metaphor of what the
arrow represents and making it a literal
thing he's turning from metaphorical
justice into literal justice as the
spectre the number one WTF the
anti-monitor kills the monitor in wipes
the last remaining earth this is their
snap sure everybody being gone except
pariah is able to save a couple of them
by sending them to the vanishing point
from legends of tomorrow obviously this
is meant to represent the snap-in
infinity war you end with the downer
ending but you have a part two that's
coming up their version of Avengers
endgame where they bring everything back
because technically there is no
multiverse right now when the monitor
also calls him mobius he's also doing a
little bit of the new 52 retcon of the
anti-monitor character talking about his
origin story the way he became the
anti-monitor is that he was born as the
person mobius on the planet chord and he
wanted to find the anti-life equation so
he built the mobius chair the one that
you see the new guy
Metron flying around in all the time but
when Mobius in the Mobius chair found
the anti-life equation it cursed him and
turned him into what you see is the
anti-monitor now I don't know if they're
gonna get into the anti-life equation
during this or if they're gonna invoke
any of the new gods Easter eggs or
anything like that but there are two
more hours in the crossover left I
talked about why Lila flipped sides for
the anti-monitor in my last episode -
video that's just another comic book
moment from crisis on Infinite Earths he
just mind controls her and pariah to do
what he wants for the most part if you
don't remember the vanishing point that
was the place that they went to at the
end of legends of tomorrow season one so
they're just sort of stuck there on an
island outside of space-time until they
can come back and defeat the
anti-monitor but that's not the end of
it because Lex Luthor winds up being
really important to the end of the
crossover he swaps places with Kingdom
Come Superman
using The Book Of Destiny making himself
one of the Paragons they even have a
funny joke where he sort of literally
writes it on a piece of paper but part
two of the crossover will come back at
the end of January of course we'll do
videos for that and I'll do a trailer
video for part four and it talked a
little bit more about Oliver being the
new Spectre of the DC Universe if he
spotted any big Easter eggs in the
episode that I didn't include in the
video just write them below in the
comments while you wait for everything
click here for my crisis on Infinite
Earths episode 2 video and click here
for that brand new Wonder Woman 1984
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]